[Music]  the controversial Pepsi ad that has  everybody talking at Kendall Jenner  handing a police officer a Pepsi  [Applause]  many called the ad tone-deaf and  exploitive Pepsi pulled the ad within 24  hours and released a statement admitting  they missed the mark and apologized for  putting Kendall Jenner in that position  I want to do this and I want to be a  part of it but it just makes me nervous  like what people are gonna think of it  kendall has since deleted all tweets  about the ad and has not commented on  the backlash but a source close to the  model tells ET she is quote devastated  and claims she did not see the creative  vision beforehand because she quote  relied on Pepsi to do their due  diligence and trusted that it would be  tasteful et has reached out to Jenner  and Pepsi's reps for further comment  [Music]